hey guys Joey here and if you got
hankering for some World War 2 RTS
battles this gameplay from sunstrike 4
will be right up your alley if you want
to see more videos like this throws like
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel on YouTube
stay strong comrades you must protect
the convoy at all costs the survival of
the city depends on it we enforce the
defense line at the center and be
prepared for anything
because as did the Germans have noticed
that we are moving our supplies over the
lake prepare for incoming attacks
[Music]
that touch that
[Music]
the Germans cannot deploy heavy tanks
the ice is too thin for that expect
strong infantry assaults instead
comrades
[Music]
[Music]
I got it
because of booty
no jack
[Music]
got a footing
[Music]
reinforcements arrived
turn the thin ice to our advantage
comrade use explosives to shatter the
ground under the enemy units
right this vato
yeah yeah
negatory because it because it yeah that
you do because it because I got away
reinforcements arrived because of food
because a Gotama loser
yeah
focus off because of putting your
preheated caught a job you got a job
Aquatica Sawa
three views our scouts report that enemy
troops are advancing from the north
reinforce the northern defense line
comrade
gabor get off
able to dock delusion listen black
because of forty tonight
because the reinforcements arrived they
do
because I got away because I got away
a dark illusion
got a job what do they do
[Music]
[Applause]
because of footage for the footage
because the footage
I know
all right men we are here to secure this
region for our advance towards Paris our
main objective is to capture a la
Luzerne just north of us these hedgerows
are ideal for the crowds to set up an
ambush so be on your guard
everyone move on capture the nearby
fields to create a safe passage for the
armored brigade commander infantry
moving infantry on the move enemy
infantry moving infantry moving got it
got it
machine gun movin
moving infantry on the move
[Music]
if the tree on the move machine gun
movin
yes sir
medic movie
yes sir moving sir
hostile units on the way gene gun moving
moving where you need me moving where
you need me medic moving infantry on the
moon permit
in theory reinforcements have arrived
target in sight
infantry moving medic movie yes sir all
the way moving good job and by well the
air force recons the area infix
operation boundaries are extended
reporters reporting for duty yes
reporting for duty awaiting orders
infantry moving boy those AAA batteries
HQ won't risk any more of our birds
until they're taken care of
moving got it
reinforcements arrived moving firm ative
awaiting orders yes sir
moving where you need me machine gun
movin
yes firm ative hostile unit spotted
machines on movin yes sir infantry
moving infantry on the move
come on yes pirates shortage shoot them
infantry moving medic movie infantry on
the move seat is a machine gun movin
infantry moving
hostile units spotted